Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David, here's a very aggressive voicemail
question.
Speaker 5: Yes, David.
Just curious, I want your show from time to
time.
I was curious as to why you never talked about
Hunter Biden.
Yeah.
And all the millions of dollars that he has
received from China and Russia.
And the fact that that is probably why Joe
Biden does not take any action towards either
one of those countries because he has been
compromised.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Listen, so first of all, most of the things
that this caller said who is interestingly,
sounds a lot like Troy York and also calls
from Illinois, but apparently is a different
caller.
First of all, those claims are essentially
all unproven.
It's unproven that Hunter Biden received money
from those governments.
There is an investment firm co-founded by
Hunter Biden, which did have a consulting
agreement with the mayor of Moscow.
It involves a whole bunch of other people.
There is no evidence that Joe Biden got any
money or that Joe Biden is involved in any
way.
And most importantly, Hunter Biden isn't involved
in the administration in any way.
You know, Ivanka Trump, Eric Trump, Don Jr.
They were highly present in Donald Trump's
administration.
They were sitting at the table.
Ivanka sat at the table at what was at the
G8 or the G20 or whatever it was filling in
for then Secretary of State Rex Tillerson.
And these very same people that now want to
draw some link to Joe Biden from things Hunter
Biden did in the past, allegedly.
And Hunter has no involvement whatsoever in
Joe Biden's administration.
Where were they on Ivanka, Eric, Don Jr. and
Jared Kushner during the Trump administration?
These people are pathetic.
And there is really no what am I going, Hunter?
But what do you want to talk about a hunter
Biden who the guys know where he's?
He's not present in any way or involved at
all.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I won't even tell you what's on today's bonus,
Joe.
It's a good one.
Sign up it.
Join Pacman Ackerman
Unidentified: will get instant access.